thinking about measures of central
tendency is much easier when you just
have an actual set of data a bunch of
scores and you just kind of tally things
up you get them in order and you think
ah well okay here's how I can do a
calculation to find the average or
here's you know me putting them in order
and having a look at which score happens
to be in the middle so all of our
measures of central tendency mode median
and mean are pretty easy sitting in our
head when we think about concrete data
sets like that but when it comes to
probability density functions and
probably distributions we have to think
about these same ideas mean mode and
median through a sort of different lens
so the first one we had a look at was
the mode if you've got something which
is the most common score in your data
set then it makes sense that's the most
probable score to occur if you were to
choose one at random so if it's the most
probable one then on your probability
density function you're going to be
looking for the highest probability and
that happens in a variety of ways for
example you know if you are gonna use
calculus then a stationary point which
ends up being a maximum turning point
may be where your highest probability is
but that's not always the case you know
you've got a function like this where
you've got a stationary point down here
but it's a minimum so you're going to
get the highest probability in the mode
existing at an endpoint and even if you
do find a stationary point that's a
maximum if it's a local maximum and it's
only relative to that little area then
the global maximum which is the true
highest probability it's gonna be
somewhere else it's going to be on an
endpoint also so this is what we had a
look at with the mode and then we
introduced this idea of the median being
in the middle of the data set now
because I don't know what my actual data
points are I can't just
line them up in ascending or descending
order and then just say the middle one
is right here okay I have to think about
what the probability density function
will tell me about where the median is
and because the median splits your data
set into two what we can say is that not
only is it in two but it's in two equal
halves if you have a look at the lower
half over here the probability of
selecting that lower half again if we
chose at random would be 50% so because
that corresponds to this integral down
here I can say that if I evaluate this
integral then it'll give me an answer
that's known a half so if I'm trying to
find the median as long as I know like
say the lower boundary and what the
probability density function actually is
then this median Q 2 will be the only
unknown left and so I can solve for Q 2
in that way correspondingly or
conversely I should say you could do it
from the other end so if you knew what
the upper boundary was and in some cases
with a data set you only get given a one
sided restriction so I know we had a
look recently at a function a
probability density function and it was
defined in in this domain X is greater
than or equal to 50 so in this case um
you would use the lower boundary here
but I could do it the other way around
if I said you've got a particular
function and it's only defined for
values less than 50 or equal to 50 as
well um you have to use the upper
boundary and thankfully it's exactly the
same technique because the meaning is in
the middle so from the median to the
upper boundary you should still get an
area of 1/2 so 50/50 total areas one
like every probability density function
so we've already looked at the example
of where you get given the two
boundaries and then you have to find the
median from that and but you can
actually go in reverse there's no reason
why if you know the median you can
actually go in the opposite direction
and find out what the boundaries are if
that happens to be useful too so here's
an example of how we can sort of play
this out if you get given a probability
density function and it's defined as x
over 4 within some domains so you can
see here and I'll just highlight it for
you you've got an unknown on both ends
of your probability density function so
you're like I don't know where I start I
don't know where I end but I do know
number 1 let's highlight it with a
different color what the function is and
I also know getting onto the questions I
also know the median value it happens to
be 3 right so how do I use this piece of
information to then calculate what the
lower and upper bounds are of this
distribution well what I'm going to do
just come back to this diagram here is
I'm going to use these two pieces of
knowledge that from the lower boundary
to the median that will give me a half
and from the median to the upper
boundary
that integral will also give me a half I
can use them to evaluate what a and B
are because in this case I know what q2
is it's three
so let's form some integrals is question
one let's form two integrals that that
make this statement right so the
integral from the lowest boundary which
I don't know up to the median which is
three of my particular function which in
this case is x over four if I integrate
that that should give me fifty percent
of the scores so it's probability will
be a half and in exactly the same way I
can say from the median up to the upper
boundary the upper bound if I take that
same function and find the area that's
relevant there I should get a half as
well so using each of these two
integrals and the fact that the only
unknown in each one is the lower
boundary here and the upper boundary
here I can solve for this let's see how
that plays out this particular function
i'm exxon for when I integrate it its
primitive is x squared on eight so I'll
pop that in here and then I need to
evaluate it at its two boundaries I know
what the answer to that definite
integral be it's a half so now what I
need to do is the substitution both
three and a will go into x squared and
so that will leave me with the unknown
being a so let's have a go and see what
happens there
right we evaluate the upper boundary and
then we subtract from evaluating the
lower battery so I'm getting this that
gives me a half over there I
instinctively dislike the fact that
there are so many fractions around so
I'm just trying to reduce my cognitive
load a little bit so I'm gonna multiply
everything through by the lowest common
multiple of all these denominators that
that'll get rid of all the fractions for
me so in this case the lowest common
multiple of eight and two is eight so
I'll multiply through by that and that
leaves me with three squared or 9 over
there leaves me with an a squared here
and eight lots of 1/2 is 4 so I now want
to isolate my unknown a so I'm gonna
make that the subject so I will subtract
9 from both sides I've got an undesired
track 9 I said No
but what I meant was for takeaway 9
which is negative 5
double-check that and then I get rid of
that negative don't do two things at the
same time all right now at this point I
want to find what a is so I take the
square roots of both sides but I notice
that every quadratic you know you when
you take the square root of both sides
you're going to get a positive and a
negative result here now we've seen in
the past we've looked at situations
where instinctively we get rid of the
negative result because if we're it's
something we're measuring like a length
or sometimes a time you know negative
time or negative length don't tend to
have a meaning in the situation that
we're you know looking at but we've also
seen that in situations like this you
actually sometimes do want the negative
answer it's the positive answer you need
to disregard so we don't want to just
draw any quick conclusions we want to
think carefully about the probability
density function that relates to this
question and then work out what the
probability density function tells us
about which answer is invalid so let's
go all the way back to the start of the
question and this is something we kind
of um skirted over because it wasn't
immediately relevant to us if you have a
look at this function here x over 4 we
know that because it's told to us this
is a probability density function I mean
has to obey two particular conditions so
one of the conditions is the one that
we're using at the moment which is that
the integral from the lower boundary to
the upper boundary of this probability
density function within the boundaries
that are appropriate it should equal one
and we're using that fact by dividing
that into halves and saying here's the
bottom half and he's the top ha
so we've already used that fact but the
other condition is that the function
within the domain that's provided it has
to be greater than or equal to 0 and the
reason for that is because there is no
such thing as a negative probability if
something's not going to happen it
doesn't have negative probability it has
zero probability so this fact here is
relevant to me because it means it
implies a restriction on a and B because
this function over here x on 4 it's not
always positive right if I just draw it
like a really quick and dirty sketch
here I'm x on for what kind of a graph
is this going to give us
well it is a straight line x over 4 but
X is just a ^ 1 so that's why it's a
straight line and then it's Sun excuse
me
sneeze that didn't turn up um it's
gradients gonna be very shallow do you
see that it's gonna be it's like 1/4 X
so it's a very sort of shadow line that
passes through the mist let's try that
again that passes through the origin
like so you can clearly see even from
this very very rough drawing that part
of this graph is outside of you know
what a probability density function can
be the only part that's allowed is this
part over here that is greater than or
equal to zero so what that means is I
really need to disregard this left-hand
section over here I know it can't
possibly be part of the probability
density function so what I can say is
that due to this fact that's in
different color due to this fact that
the probability density function has to
be greater than or equal to 0 and the
shape of it has some implications for a
and B namely you can see it over here
and be a x-values right there horizontal
values here so a and B both have to be
in this positive side and you can see
how this is going to help us determine
which of the answers we just got for a
is valid and which one is invalid the
way we would state this the way would
capture it is by saying since our
function has to be greater than or equal
to 0 for this particular domain what
this implies is that number 1 um a can't
be negative right so a is the lower
boundary so the lowest it can be is is a
zero okay so it can't be negative so
I've got 0 being less than or equal to a
and I also know that a and B can't be
equal to each other because then you
wouldn't have the probability density
function couldn't possibly it's area
couldn't possibly add up to 1 so
therefore um a can't equal B so that's
why I don't have the equality on that it
has to be bigger right but what's
important is that means they're both
positive so now when I come over to here
I've got this a equals plus or minus
root 5 but I can say since a has to be
- zero a can't possibly be the negative
results so a equals the square root of
five
only fantastic so this is my lower
boundary what I'm gonna try and do is go
through this same process but work it
out for the upper boundary over here and
thankfully for us a lot of them working
is very very similar for example I don't
have to integrate a whole new function
it's still X on for so I know that it's
primitive will still be x squared on
eight my boundaries are slightly
different it's not from a to three it's
from three to B but they both equal to a
half just like I had in the other
situation you're going to get a very
similar theme when you go ahead and
evaluate your boundaries as well because
you've got B squared on eight take away
three squared on eight does that seem
familiar it should and just like before
my ending is to get rid of those
fractions so I'm gonna multiply by eight
just like I did earlier so I get B
squared minus nine equals four now
things diverge I'm not subtracting 9
from both sides I'm adding 9 to both
sides so I get B squared equals 13 and
let's continue our working over here so
we don't run into the other working I'm
gonna get B equals plus or minus the
square root of 13 and in exactly the
same way as I did before I can say since
B is greater than zero
remember can even equal zero because
then a would also equal zero you're
going to get the positive one only
square root of 13 there we go so just
double check have I answered the
question if the median is three what are
the lower and upper bounds of this
distribution and the answer is yeah I
found them they are right here
they should be root five that's the
lower boundary and B should be rude 13
the upper boundary and before you
progress on to the second question that
you can see here let's just visually
confirm what's going on here right now
here's something I prepared earlier
it's the probability density function X
on 4 and you can see I hadn't restricted
it when I first read this because I
didn't know where the restrictions were
but what you can see is for starters if
i zoom in over here these are the values
that we have
right first there was the median and
that was just provided to us and then we
had the square root of five and the
square root of 13 so where are they they
are on either side if you go into your
calculator and I get a decimal
approximation for root five and root 13
these are the values that you'll turn up
with and I'm thankfully because I use
technology to help me you know you can
even see the green the orange areas are
looking equivalent because they are
indeed equal to each other so if I get
rid of this guy here those two areas are
both equal to 1/2 and you can see me
double checking that using technology to
verify the integral bear there's the
half and there's the half as well